あ?　え?
え?
何かあるかとゴミ箱を準備しておりました。
こっちがカーテンだな？
おっしゃーー！！
カーテンが無いととにかく撮影することもできないので
やー！
はい、という訳で、新・・・
なに?
わあーー！！
はい、という訳で久しぶりの新居でございます。はじめしゃちょーです
最近はそんなに東京に来ることなくて、来なかったんですけども
やっぱり週末とかになるとちょっと忙しいので、東京に居る事があります。
取りあえずね、俺はね、ここで生活する気は、無い。
生活する気はないんですけども
必要最低限の物とかね？まぁ生活に必要な物はどんどん買って行こうと思ってるんで
今の所ですね、買ったのが、さっき届いたゴミ箱と、カーテン。
シャンプー、リンス、お風呂のあの椅子。布団。
以上です。
調理器具も買わないし、冷蔵庫も多分買わない。
洗濯機が欲しいなと思ってるんですけど、多分実際にですね、またここでどれくらい生活するのかってのが解ってないので、
そこ等辺はもうちょっと様子を見て色んなものを買って行ければな、と思っております。
と言う訳でちょっとまだ汚いんですけども、どんな感じの新居かなってのを今回ﾁｮｯﾄ紹介して行こうかな、と
思っております、では行こう!
まあ、特にパット見ねそんなねぇ、超巨大な部屋って言う訳でもないですけども、
そこそこ部屋が空いてます
まずはこちらが、メインルーム。
おそらく撮影とかはこの部屋になるかなと思っております。
もう汚なっ...
キッチン的なことも有るんですけども、ここ等辺をどう使うかってのもちょっと考え物ですね
ここは編集部屋になると思います。
この子も連れてきちまったよ...
ここからは多分未公開ですね
全く新しい部屋でございます
ここがね、取りあえず寝室です
ゴー！
ここは多分寝るだけの部屋ですね。
服とかはね、多分こん中に入れると思うんですけども、まぁ何もありません。
かくれんぼに使えそうですね
もうひとつここに部屋があるんですけども、ここに関してはまだどう使おうか何も考えてないです。
取りあえず、有ります
ゴー！
カーテン足りてないんだけど。
カーテンが全然足りてないんだけど。
えー、こちらはまだ何にもないっすね。
ここは多分物置とかになるのかなぁ。
ちょっとまだ使い道がよくわからない部屋でございます。
次！
見せたことがあるかなぁ。突発して何か言うこともないんですけども…
強いて言うなら、ここ。シャワールーム。
ここがシャワールームでございます。
ひとまず椅子は買ったぞ。
はい。という感じのお部屋になっております。
特にこう...なにかすごいってわけでもないんですけど...
まぁ、寝て泊まって撮影するには十分なお部屋だとおもいます。
ただ、シャワーが３方向に出るのはちょっとね、新しい技術かなと思いました。
ありがとうございます。
というわけでここの部屋でですね、動画を撮ることが増えると思うんですけども
まだ何も置いてないんですよ。
まだ、机とかも何も置いてないので
まあ今後ここでどういう撮影スタイルでやっていくかっていうのをちょっとまた考えていこうとおもいます。
みなさんよかったら、何か
コメント欄で
これは買っといていいよ
みたいなやつがあったら教えてください。
参考にさせていただきます。
ジャングルジムとかサッカーゴールとかは欲しいかもしんないっすね。
というわけで、今日もちょっとバタバタしてたんですけど
東京でゆっくりおやすみします。
じゃあな!!!